[موسيقى]
في البدايه وانتم قاعدين كان عندنا حاجه
اسمها
من مكانها
صغيره دي دي بتاعتنا يعني اتمنى تبقى هنا
اوكي تمام ايه يا مصطفى
هنقول بس خليكم فاكريني في حاجه اسمها
نتكلم عنها قدام تمام واحنا صغيرين كان
دائما بيقولوا ايه بيقولوا المخ شبه
الكمبيوتر
وده مسامحه قوي ده حقيقي فعلا بس مش المخ
بقى شبه حاجه اسمها
المعالج اللي موجود جوه الكمبيوتر الانسان
طيب لو بتحب ندخل الداتا لما نحب ندخل
الداتا للكمبيوتر
يبقى فعلا
كمبيوتر
والانسان حلو
طيب
الكاميرا دي او المايك ده بغض النظر بسلك
يعني بس الكاميرا المايك بيبقى متوصل
باسلاك علشان يوصل السجن او الاشارات دي
للكمبيوتر اوكي طيب احنا بقى كباشر لما
بيبقى عندنا
الاشارات دي الاحساس زي الصوره
طيب
اشاره كهربائيه ويبدا يبعثها عن طريق
الجهاز العصبي
على شكل ايه
على شكل اشاره كهربائيه اذا احنا عندنا
اسلاك في جسمنا
الكمبيوتر صح طيب احنا كده
كلام حقيقي
اسمها ايه اسمها الجهاز العصبي المرك
زي صعب
اشارات كهربائيه
وصل له كل الاشارات الكهربائيه دي عن طريق
الاعصاب توصل للبرايم وترجع ثاني وتدينا
الاردن تمام
يلا يا ابني
كمل
تمام كمل
تمام ده اللي بيحصل بالضبط
بيحس بان في مثلا خطر زي النار دي بيبدا
يبعث الاشاره في الجهاز العصبي توصل للمخ
يبدا ينبهه شيل ايدك تمام هو ده تمام
بالراحه بالراحه
احنا عندنا هنا
بتمشي في العصب من فوق تمام
نمشي في العصب من فوق اوكي لحد ما توصل
لحاجه اسمها الحويصله العصبيه
فيها نواق العصبيه اللي هي النيورو ترانس
اللي احنا هنتكلم عنها النهارده تمام
اول ما بيوصل لها الاشاره الكهربيه بتبدا
تنقل للعصب اللي بعده طيب ليه ليه ده
بيحصل ليه ما بتكملش الاشاره الكهربيه لحد
العصب اللي بعده هاقول لكم ليه هل
الكهرباء ينفع تمشي في الفراغ
عليك كهربائي ينفع تمشي في الهواء
بس الاجابه انه فعلا الكهرباء
بنشوفه ده كهرباء كهرباء بس محتاجه فرق
جهد مجهول ما بينسى حاجتين علشان الكهرباء
دي تظهر هل الكلام ده ينفع يحصل على
الاسكال بتاع مستحيل
علشان كده احنا محتاجين نوع ثاني من
الاشارات غير الاشاره الكهربيه يوصل
الاشاره بتاعتنا دي من العصب من العصب
اللي بعده طيب هتبقى عباره عن ايه عباره
عن كلمه عباره عن اشاره
تمام تمام
اللي بتطلع من العصب الاول تمشي في الفراغ
كهربائيه
لو قلت
ايه اللي يحصل
دي قلت في امراض كثير جدا جدا جدا احنا
هنا سمعنا عنها بس ما نعرفش هي بيحصل انك
بتحصل ازاي حد يسمع هنا عن حاجه
جميل جميل
عباره عن مصر
[موسيقى]
فعلا امراض القرن الحالي مش بس بيعطلك عن
حياتك اليوم ممكن يوصل لحاجه خطيره جدا
بسبب حاجه بسيطه جدا
فاحنا هنتكلم النهارده عن
دور اللي احنا اتكلمنا عنه في الاول لما
قلنا ممكن نقف والاندرويد
عشان كده احنا فعلا محتاجين ان احنا
نتعلمها
من فوائد
تعبان
وتصحى الصبح
[موسيقى]
قدامك نسمع الكلمه بتاعتك يا عم انت ما
بتروح الجيم ليه يقول لك اه والله باروح
الجيم اطلع زي ايه اطلع همم هل التوتر
اللي عندي راحه اطلع قرف هناك ده حقيقي
لان الاندلس بيتريوس والاسترس ده كلام
فعلا حقيقي بين الوظيفه
اوكي
تمام قلنا
ايه
يبقى لحظه لحظه
يوم طويله النهارده وجاي تعبان
الكلام ده فعلا الحقيقي ده هنتفق
فعلا ان هو بيزود الان هيخليك فعلا
الشمس الشمس احنا مقصرين في حق نفسنا فعلا
ان احنا بنبقى في ناس قاعده كده طول الوقت
بتاعها في المكتب الساعه 9:00 الصبح 8
الصبح لحد الساعه 5:00 المغرب قاعد في
المكتب الشمس ده حرام نفسه من حاجات كثير
طبعا
الشمس غير كمان الميلاتونين اللي بيقي من
السكن كمان ضوء الشمس
وبيحسن ابراهيم
انت تضحك مع اصحابك في ابسط من كده يا
جماعه في اسهل من كده حاجات تحسن الموت
بتاعنا وتحسن بتاعتنا وتخلينا فعلا ان
احنا نقدر نعمل
العواطف بتاعتنا
انا دلوقتي
كنترول انت متخيل ان انت ممكن
حسن برده
يقول لك خذ البرشام ده هتاكل كويس عشان
تتخن اه الكلام ده حقيقي
كثير
ما شاء الله
المناطق المسؤوله عن الاسلوب
النوم هتلاقي الشخص ده
بتاثر على المناطق اللي كنترول
الشهيه هتلاقي الشخص ده بياكل هتلاقي وزنه
كل
الناس
المسؤول عن ابي طالب هتلاقي نفسك بتزود
الشهريه
اكيد حد سامع الحته دي اخذنا دواء انت
ماشي
خالص كمان حاجه
هنتكلم
في اكلات معينه ممكن ناكلها تزود
السيليكون ايه ده يا مصطفى انت بتقول ايه
يعني ينفع اكل اكل
لا هو فعلا السيليتونين ما ينفعش يتاخذ من
الاكل بشكل مباشر ولكن في الاكل بيحتوي
على حاجه اسمها التربته فعلا ودي اللي
100صنع منها في الجسم الانسان الفراخ
ستيفن هوكينج بالعربي
كثير اوكي لو ان الناس دي افراد دي فعلا
بيبقى عندهم حاجه اسمها
ايه بسبب ان ما فيش فعلا شمس الحته دي ما
فيش فيها شمس وشمس مهمه جدا ان هي
بتشتمونه 12 السيليتونا لدرجه ان في ستديو
بتقول ان اوبو 5
عندهم ماشي
سوري في واحده ثانيه
اخر حاجه اسمها
هاطلع
والله العظيم زعلان كده كويس
شاورما
مش هنقدر نكمل هنتكلم على حاجه
همم
[موسيقى]
فتحت اول مشروع اللي هي اول صيدليه
في مصر
همم طبعا ده بفضل ربنا سبحانه وتعالى ولكن
التايم ما نجم يا جماعه ده حاجه من اهم
الحاجات اللي احنا لازم نفك عليها طيب
بمديره تكنيك انا انصح بها كل الناس اللي
هي دلوقتي بتذاكر لان هي فعلا تكنيك ممتاز
عمله واختارها واحد اسمه همم فرانشيسكو
بيقول ايه بيقول ان انت تاسك تحدد مهمه
معينه هتقوم بها
لمده 25 دقيقه ثواني 5
على 25 دقيقه تمام
بعد ال 25
نعمل
نشوف الشمس بس ده كفايه قوي
ناخذ 25 دقيقه ذاكر ثاني مثلا 25 دقيقه
اول
بتاعك يرجع زي الاول هتلاقي نفسك بنفس ال-
انا مش حابب اطول على حضراتكم دي كل
الكونتر بتاعتي لو حد حابب يسال اي حاجه
او عنده فيسبوك
انستغرام تويتر
[تصفيق]